hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're in
round 4 of our coverage the 2018 tata
steel's tournaments our competitors
today White's can be played by Vladimir
Kramnik he's had three games and he's
had a win loss and a draw for the the
trifecta
and his opponent Peter Svidler playing
the black pieces has three draws so they
are tied with one and a half points
going into round 4 both in striking
distance if either these players can win
they would only be half a points behind
the leader so looking to get off to a
strong start with a 12 round tournaments
here in round number 4 so we get started
with White's Vladimir plays Knight to f3
followed by Knight to f6 I thought for
sure we were gonna see the BET drop
defense just because we've been saying
that all tournament long it seems like
but instead we see pawn to g3 pawn to d5
so it looks like black is playing a
grünfeld defense Bishop here to g2 Cass
on the Kings side and then we do morph
into the grünfeld opening which is
somewhat interesting because we normally
don't see a fee and keto on the Kings
side in at the ground fell but that's
exactly what we see both sides are fin
kiddo to the Kings side of the board
they have castled and now we have pawn
over here to c4 so the Queens gambit
declined type of lines that was a couple
options that black has here he could
play pawn to c6 not take this pawn could
also decide to take this pawn and then
gonna be met with Knight to a3 attacking
the pawn usually just gonna give this
pawn back if he did want to hold on to
it Bishop to e6 makes some sense it does
block off this pawn from pushing forward
now I could play say g5 attacking the
bishop bishop could come here to d5 pawn
to e4 white putting a lot of pressure
forcing his opponent to move his bishop
all over the place pawn to h6 forcing
the knight to move but let's go ahead
and capture some material here pawn
takes on d5
recaptures night takes have here on c4
Knight takes and then Bishop takes that
pawn here on g5 on all this is gonna be
very very good for for white he has
Center control here black was not able
to hold on to that material like he had
hoped for so this is one option that
black could go down both sides might not
play exactly like this if we do see an
exchange here on a c4 but after five
minutes Peter decided to play the move
pawn to c6 which was his other option up
until this point both sides been rapid
fire three or four seconds per move and
then thought for a minute and then after
five minutes decide to play pawn to c6
Meta Knight up here to e5 and so if you
look at it many people would see this
and they say you know this is a normal
move Knight to c3 but as you can tell
from this situation we just looked at
now pawn takes on c4 doesn't look as
intriguing for White's perspective you
can't bring the knight here to a3 many
times in the Queen's game a decline
lines you still have your bishop here on
f1 and so after you play pawn to e3 you
still have that LightSquared Bishop to
attack the square you don't have that
when you think hit o to the King side of
the board so White's not looking to
bring his Knight to c3 yet instead we
see denied up here to e5 trying to
continue to be aggressive black
continues with Bishop to e6 and then we
see the pend capture Bishop recapture
and then that up here to see three
things are safe for the night to get
involved this also does attack the
bishop now normally you wouldn't see the
bishop take here you would see the pawn
capture so that the knight wouldn't come
up here and force your bishop to move
but Peters fiddler looks like hasn't
been super comfortable in the positions
he's taking a few minutes every move and
so I think he saw this and just said I'm
gonna go ahead and exchange material if
I can get down to more of a draw state
that's fine for me so it decides to go
in exchange for LightSquared Bishop off
the board
King recaptures here on a g-tube and
then Knight to d7 can't bring it here to
c6 that natural square so d7 also great
move attacks this Knight
here on e5 also adds protection to this
knight on f6 white plays Queen to b3 and
I thought we might actually see this
earlier instead the Knight to e5 move
the main line would be Queen to b3 this
makes a ton of sense but in the game
decided to play that Knight to e5 and
later on only after Knight to d7 that we
see Queen up here to b3 just getting it
more active involvement to the game
allows the rook to come over to d1 and
to support this pawn on d4 trying to be
aggressive to this Queen it attacks the
pawn here on it b7 black says yeah I'm
completely located with the exchange of
material let's go ahead to exchange off
Queens that should make things easier
for me so Queen to b6 White's not ready
to do that quite yet first plays rook to
d1 and then we do see in exchange now
white does have double pawns here on the
B file not necessarily what he's looking
for black definitely has a better pawn
structure what white does have going for
him is control of the center of the
board right now so very very aggressive
from blacks point of view he doesn't
have either of his rooks activated a
white hasn't won the center of the board
ready to push forward this work here on
a1 is threatening black you this rook
can't move this pawn here on a7 would
fall black would have to use another
move just play something like pawn to a6
to stop that attack but very easy for
white to get his other pieces involved
into the game so we'll see how this
develops from here the rook now swings
to a c8 says yeah I'm seeing some stuff
happen on the Queen side not too worried
about the the Queen the King side of the
board some of the maneuver my rook to c8
pawn up to f4 so what I like about this
move is it continues the pressure from
White's perspective he can't stay
passive at all and he can't just sit
back and let his opponent just trade off
pieces until the very end
black would have a better end game I
think with the better pawn structure
especially here with the double pawns on
the B file I think Y could overwhelm him
on the Queen side of the board so if
Latimer correctly says I need to
continue to be aggressive so let's go
ahead and play pawn up to f4 pawn to c5
trying to break up the center of the
board Bishop to e3 to protect that pond
we do see an exchange in the rook takes
you know if you can't look at and say
can the bishop take the bishop
absolutely can the reason for the rook
taking here on d4 you'll see very
quickly after the Knight takes on e5 the
pawn recaptures forcing the knight to
move knights gonna come back here to e8
and now rook to d7 would not be possible
if the bishop took here on d4 and really
wanted to control the seventh ranked
rooks do a fine job of attacking on open
files and against their opponent really
want to be on the seventh rank if you're
white and if you're black you definitely
want to be on this second rank back here
so from now White's attacking a lot of
squares this pawn on e7 attacking this
pawn here on b7 still has to worry about
this rook here on a1 as well as this
Bishop on e3 double attacking the square
here on a7 so black is in a tough spot
yes the bishop here on g7 can take this
pawn on e5 but why it's gonna be able to
easily get material back in that's gonna
be completely fun you know he had the
double pawns here he wasn't expecting to
hold on to both of these pawns
anyway so that's gonna be completely
fine rook to c7 trying to trade off some
material I was he rigged up here to a7
what's nice is white can dictate how
these exchanges go there's not a good
way for black to really counter that
decides to play rook to b8 could have
taken on a7 if he wanted to but instead
decides to play rook to b8 now rook down
to d5 protecting the bishop says hey
I've got this pawn to material now I'm
gonna come down protect this pawn see if
I can go up upon advantage here upon to
b6 just says I want to I want to
exchange some material but keep in mind
this pawn is now being attacked by this
bishop so it does open up a few more
opportunities for for white to attack
blacks point of view I just think black
is in a really really tough spot he has
nothing aggressive going on he's just
playing defense and he's just kind of
waiting to see how White's going to
attack him the knight comes up here to
beef
very aggressive squared defends this
rook here attacking the rook here we do
see an exchange as you can imagine
blacks trying to exchange as much as
possible
the knight takes here on a 7 King to f8
just preparing for the knight to c6 and
then taking here on e7 that'd be very
difficult for black to deal with since
he doesn't have any other great move
decides let's go ahead and bring that
King over here to f8 now white continues
to press his advantage brings the rook
back up here to d7 and then rook to a8
attacking the knight and then Bishop to
d4 and what's interesting is in this
position black resigned now I get it if
you look at this you could say blacks in
a very tough spot there's no way he
could really come back for this but I
would like to think that black could at
least give it a good college try and
just see what he could come out of it
worse could happen he you could lose I
mean that's that's about as bad as you
get but when you resign same things I'm
not exactly sure why he resigned
if play were to continue my guess is it
would look something like this there's a
discovered attack with pawns who to e6
you could have seen pawn to f6 trying to
blow up the attack here nothing really
looks good here pawn to e6 what's nice
about this is it limits some of the
squares that king can go to also adds
protection for this rook on d7 maybe the
knight tries to come out wasn't doing
anything on the e8 Square Knight to c6
this is just deadly because now we have
two attackers the knight and the rook on
the e7 square maybe the knight comes
down here to e7 trying to get involved
attack the opponent but doesn't have
enough material to really attack their
opponent this is all going to be bad y
can continue to gobble up pieces very
quickly he can start attacking here on
the King side of the board while black
could have found of better moves than
these I do think it would have fallen
downhill very quickly I still would have
liked to see black continued just to see
we could have come up with but thinking
the day black decided to resign just a
few moves before I threw Bishop here to
d4 so congratulations to Vladimir
he played a great game and at the end of
day he's now a half a point behind the
leaders so Peters filler definitely
falls after this three draws and a loss
is not going to cut it so far
but all-in-all great game I just think
White was way more prepared every single
move it seemed like from Petersburg Side
was three to five minutes some of them
even longer than that eight to ten
minutes where normally people were
prepared you know half the moves or five
to ten seconds because they've gone
through this in the lab with their team
ready and that's exactly what we saw
from Vladimir he had 45 minutes left
where you see Peter there with just
about 10 minutes or so so at the end of
the day congratulations to Vladimir
great game hopefully you guys enjoyed
Round four
I will see you guys in the next video
round five